كان الموقع في يوم من الأيام
مركزًا سريًا للأسلحة البيولوجية في الحرب الباردة
ومغلقًا إلى الأبد ، لكن سي إن إن
حصلت على وصول حصري
إلى منشأة عالية التقنية حيث
تصنع روسيا الآن
سبوتنيك ضد لقاح مثير للجدل لكن
لقاح كوفيد 19 فعال ، والجزء
المهم التالي هو الحصول على لقاح
نقي إضافي  يجب معايرة المياه النظيفة والمعقمة في
كل خطوة في العملية واسعة النطاق
بعناية ، أخبرني كبير العلماء
بتأخير الإنتاج الضخم للسبوتنيك الخامس
المعتمد في أغسطس من العام الماضي
حتى الآن ، وهل قمت بالفعل بهذه
الخطوة ، هل أنت الآن تنتج
ملايين اللقاحات بالملايين  من الجرعات
كل شهر ،
نعم ، نحن ننتج عدة ملايين من
اللقاحات كل
شهر ونأمل قريبًا الحصول على
كمية أعلى
ربما مثل 10 أو 20 مليونًا شهريًا
مع هذه الأرقام يقول المسؤولون الروس الآن
أي شخص بالغ يتمتع بصحة جيدة هنا
يريد أن يحصل على سبوتنيك في  إنها
تفتح عيادات منبثقة مثل هذه الموجودة في
مركز تجاري في موسكو
لتشجيع المتسوقين على الحصول على التطعيم
وتقديم آيس كريم مجاني  مع كل
ضربة لتحلية الصفقة ، حتى
المختبر الروسي السري
الذي كان رائدًا في sputnik v قد فتح أبوابه
لتقديم اللقاح مباشرة كما كان
من المصدر ،
حسنًا ، أنا لا أشعر بالقلق
حيال الحصول على
اللقاح الروسي لأنه في  هذه
اللحظة لأنك تعلم أنها خضعت لتجارب إكلينيكية واسعة النطاق
وتمت مراجعتها من قبل الأقران في مجلة اه الرئيسية
ووجد أنها آمنة جدًا
وأن 91 6
1.6 فعال وهو أمر جيد جدًا على
أي حال ، لقد
فات الأوان الآن لأنه  لقد تم
القيام بذلك
، الشيء المثير للاهتمام هو حقيقة
أنه يمكنني الحصول على لقاح هنا في روسيا
على الإطلاق نظرًا لأنني لست في
فئة معرضة للخطر ،
فالدولة التي بها أحد
أعلى معدلات الإصابة بفيروس covid19 في العالم
لديها أيضًا واحدة من  أعلى
معدلات التردد في اللقاح
أقل من 40 في المائة على استعداد للحصول
على ضربة بالكوع وفقًا لاستطلاع رأي حديث ،
تعتقد أن فلاديمير بوتين سيتقدم
إلى الأمام لتهدئة
مخاوف الجمهور على عكس العديد من دول العالم الأخرى.
يقول الكرملين إنه سيعلن عن
موعد إجراء التطعيم الرئاسي ،
لكن في بلد يتطلع إلى
رجله القوي لقيادة
لقاحه ، فإن تردده في الحصول على اللقاح لا يفعل شيئًا
لتعزيز الثقة في أن
اللقاح المعبأ والمسمى هو  تم تخزينها
قبل توزيعها أه على
المريض
، وهذه هي الطريقة التي يتم بها
توزيع عدد الجرعات في هذا الوعاء الذي
لا يزال أكثر من 50 دولة قد
طلبت الآن sputnik v
وفقًا لصندوق الثروة السيادية لروسيا rdif ،
ربما لا يزال الروس يتجاهلون
لقاحهم  نفس الصناديق تذهب إلى
الأرجنتين والبرازيل
ودول أخرى أينما ذهبت
في العالم ، لكن الطلب العالمي
على سبوتنيك الخامس يستمر في الارتفاع
ماثيو فرصة سي إن إن موسكو